on peut couvrir c'est que tf1 ne s'est
même pas fendu d'un communiqué ou pour
rassurer bernard ou pour assurer
l'association les anges non non c'est un
malentendu un quiproquo il allait
diffuser et moi je veux c'est presque un
aveu de culpabilité alors que tu veux
dire ils n'ont pas voulu diffuser ce
clip qu'on continuera à diffuser nous
dans l'émission voilà dès lundi on va le
diffuser je vous le dis mon père marc
une fois sympa c'est bien vous les
intentions mais comme ils n'ont pas
voulu diffuser ce clip on s'est dit
qu'on allait nous diffuser un clip
devant tf1
mais il ya un clip qui est bien
angoissante et qui vous prend bien la
tête
c'est bob dab dab bogdanov donc regarder
on a 4 watts de son banquet on a près
avoir un camion regarder bah voilà
regarder ces voix là on est devant tf1
est ce qu'on peut avoir un plan la
sauver voilà parce que là il ya un caméo
voilà devant alors qu'on croit pas
[Musique]
regardez regardez voilà regarder voilà
on est devant tf1 voilà donc on va
laisser ça pendant toute l'émission sera
sa demande des favoris n'ont pas voulu
diffuser le clip
voilà et on laissera même pendant toute
la nuit sachez l'eau mais voilà si si si
si on laissera ce camion alors sachez
que c'est très très fort un c4 et c'est
combien de combien droite de son nordine
non ces deux fois 300 watts et nos
ventes et mettez un peu plus forme est
un peu plus fort bêta
[Musique]
voilà et vous le mettez en bout merci et
on fera des petits pois à chaque fois
bien entendu mais j'avais dû avoir un
plan là parce qu'on a envoyé à rien on
voit même pas les gens moi c'est donc le
jour il savait réalisez vous m'appelez
merci les chéris alors vous faites un
bon rappelant pour être et on reviendra
d'accord merci mes chéris à ce que la
part allant de red bull
merci allez on va revenir on fera des
petits postes et mon petit cadeau pour
vous c'est bernard montiel tempête c'est
un progrès mais a fermé